[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
whose younger sister is in an abusive
home and he doesn't know what to do we
talk to a mom whose son is experiencing
significant mental health challenges and
we talked to a woman whose boyfriend
told her she should lose weight
for him stay tuned
[Music]
yo what up what up this is john with the
dr john baloney show
and we're so glad you are here
talking about mental health
relationships and it's a big day today
because
we're announcing
pre-sale begins for my new book own your
past change your future a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness
this is the book that's gonna send
shockwaves i don't think it's gonna send
shockwaves through anything really but
it's a great great book
the pre-reading buzz on it has been
incredible i'm excited about it i worked
real hard on this
um and if you've bought one we sold so
many tens and tens and
so many more books of redefining anxiety
than we ever imagined this is a
full-sized book this is a big book this
is um
man it's about i've told stories in this
book i've never told anywhere publicly
this is
my treaties on what's going on in the
world and why people are struggling so
much and more importantly how we can get
our head screwed back on straight get
our relationships back in order so hey
check this out in this book i'm going to
walk you through a common sense approach
to mental health and wellness as you as
you listen to the show you know i think
we've over complicated everything
everything we've created a world that
our bodies are like what are we doing
and we've pathologized everything and
dramatized everything i mean everything
about this and that
this book is going to be about the steps
on how to get connected change your
thoughts change your actions and move
you closer to who you want to be
and towards the relationships you want
to have you want to discover why you
feel so exhausted while you're lonely
why you keep doing the things you don't
want to do over and over and over you
are not broken you are not hopeless
you are enough
and you got a lot of work to do
you're worth being well so here's the
deal pre-order today
for only 20 bucks you're gonna get a ton
of free bonus items including one month
of free counseling from betterhelp they
stepped up big time to support this book
um they're offering a free month of
counseling
that's a lot
free copy of the audiobook free copy of
the ebook and more it's 20 bucks
go to johndaloni.com
and pre-order the book today let's get
this thing out out out i'm so excited to
have it out
ben you can read now right yeah you can
read now yeah i've always been able to
oh oh my bad i was thinking i was
thinking of austin that's my bad we have
a whole new crew in there james is in
there playing minecraft and we got ben
running the boards austin's there the
bearded kelly so good man zach i'm
excited to get this thing out thank you
guys for
riding with me for the last year was
kind of crazy
working this job and then riding tonight
i'm excited i'm excited all right hey
let's go to
jack in charlotte north carolina jack is
back
what's up jack how we doing
oh there you are run to the wall like
the kool-aid hello hey there you are
what's up man
am i on i was just saying uh your your
promo for that book made me want to run
through a wall so i appreciate that hey
listen don't do that just buy it don't
run through anything we need you just
kidding good for you man i'm excited i'm
excited i'm excited how are you man
i'm doing all right i've been uh
fighting a bit of a cold so i'm sorry if
my voice isn't exactly uh pleasant it's
all good and sure it's a cold as they
call it way to go sure jack so what's up
dude
um so i just have a question about my
mom i don't know exactly how to go about
encouraging her to get away from an
abusive relationship she's in okay with
my stepdad
so i'll just give some background she's
been married to him for five years now
back then i was in high school i would
stay weekends with her
and he would just he would shout he'd
curse in her face call her names
threaten her physically
it was bad enough for me that i mean i
basically hid from her i stopped doing
our visitation
and we really had
after that no contact for a year and a
half or so
he ended up in jail and she filed for
divorce for a bit
this your biological dad or a stepdad
this is my stepdad okay all right
where's your biological dad
my biological dad is still in town um
and so i ended up after i stopped seeing
my mom for that period of time um i
pretty much spent all of my time with my
biological dad who's great by the way
awesome okay cool all right so then he
your stepdad goes to jail he's a scumbag
and
then what
um so she and i started to
rebuild our relationship over the next
after the months that followed
um and while he was in prison he
basically sweet talked her found jesus
in jail and she let him back in
after six or seven months of prison he
came back
so he was he had kind of turned it
around a little bit but in the meantime
i left for college
and my little sister has started to that
was about three or so years ago and over
that time my little sister started to
tell me hey he's kind of picking up on
his old patterns you know
um so some of the things that he
he's called my mom he's saying again
he's shouting at him he's scaring them
what really scared me the most and the
reason i i guess i called you in the
first place uh was one night she
she called me and she told me
hey we had to basically hide in our own
home from this guy
um we had to lock the door because he
was shouting name calling going on one
of his uh things again
um and so i was like well you said hold
on when you said go on one of his things
and i don't mean to interrupt you this
is important
going on one of his things again what
does that mean like be very specific
what does that mean
um so he'll get going
is he smashing things is he hitting
people is he getting in people's faces
throwing things abusing like what's he
do what does that mean
uh it's slamming objects it's shouting
it's cursing calling people
um i guess cursing
i don't know about the words i can use
on the show i guess
but basically he called my mom and my
little sister a piece of [ __ ]
and i
when she told me that he was on this
rant that he was hitting things that he
was yelling
and i said hey maybe i should come back
and talk to y'all about this she was
like well i kind of wish i hadn't told
you now because i i think mom's gonna be
mad at me for telling you
oh god dude
yeah that's a classic
that's a classic statement of somebody
who's in an abusive situation
that feels responsible to make sure
mom's okay
because dad's
insane
oh man
so what are you gonna do
um
i don't know i just i want to have this
conversation with her
i do remember the last time we had a
talk like this that
proceeded you know the 18 or so month
that we really didn't talk to each other
much
i don't want to damage our relationship
and i
feel like she knows she has to know how
old are you troubling
i am 21. okay i i need you to
like i want you to tighten your fists
both of them as tight as they'll go okay
okay i want you to hold your breath take
it deep as breath as you possibly can
and hold it
one
two and then let it all out and then
relax your hands
okay
i want you to hear me directly
anything that happens from this point
forward
is not gonna be on you
it will be because you
there's a huge difference
because you're gonna act
a beautiful little girl is gonna be safe
because you're gonna act maybe but
probably not
your mom will
understand she's worth more than yet
another abusive relationship
your mom and your relationship did not
go sideways because you spoke up your
mom and your relationship went sideways
because she chose an abusive man over
you
you hear me say that
yes sir and i don't like talking about
somebody's mom but i'm being direct and
honest with you right
yes and that sucks and it hurts and it
shouldn't be that way
and then when he went to jail she came
around and realized what am i doing
and i know your mom's got her own story
and so i'm not gonna sit here and just
bash her mom
but that's the reality of what happened
she chose him
that was not your fault
and you cannot spend the rest of your
life trying to
build a bridge back towards your mom
because you're not the one that broke
the original bridge she is
okay
right
and that sucks as hard
and
you've got to let your mom know i will
call cps i'll call the police i will
call whoever my sister
will not be in this situation period
how old is this girl
she's 16.
brother she doesn't deserve that and you
know it right
yeah and that's why you're calling me
and is this your
did you cause any of this not a second
of it but now it's in your lap as a 21
year old
and your mom knows
is that fair
yeah
man
my heart's broken for you brother
for your sister for your mom for the
whole situation
so let's practice this what's it look
like
to be honest what's it look like you set
up and said tell your mom hey we need to
meet for breakfast we need to have
coffee i'm coming into town
will she meet with you
oh absolutely okay
so
i'm gonna tell you something that i tell
folks when like i worked with a group of
executives the other day um on firing
how to how to let somebody go with
dignity
and one of the things that often happens
when people are going to fire somebody
is it gets it's it's hard to take
somebody's livelihood away unless you're
a sociopath right firing somebody always
sucks i've had to do it a bunch it's not
fun
and
you end up talking too much and you're
like well you know thinking about and
then and and him hall around and it
tortures people
the most gifted
um
fire i've ever i don't know that's right
what to call that
um was a guy that taught me how to do it
the right way which is you walk in and
you sit down and say
the decision has been made you will no
longer be working here period or
i am terminating your employment here
effective immediately
this decision has been made and it is
final
that from that point forward nobody's
listening to you right so they have gone
full limbic they're not listening to you
they're in defense mode what i do what
happened i'm scared all that
what you have to do is sit down with
your mom and have the very similar
conversation
i love you and so i'm going to be direct
i've been talking to my sister and she's
in the same mess that i was in and i
will not stand for my sister to be in
this mess
period
you have 20 days or two weeks or one
week to get her out of there
or i'm going to call every official i
know tell my story tell her story and
then i'm gonna it's gonna you're gonna
deal with the authorities
i don't see another way around it do you
i don't um
are you out of college can she move in
with you i mean i guess that's another
option
no i'm still in college she couldn't
move in with me and the thing is she she
lived alone obviously while he was uh
out in jail no no i'm not talking about
your mom talking about your little
sister
oh no she can't move in with me
why not um you said that all like nah
bro i got bearded
well no no i i guess the more practical
option would be she would go and live
with my dad okay okay
and and i see what you're saying now
about it not being
my fault it being because of me i i my
thought is like i don't want to be the
guy who takes her away from my mom that
would break my heart as much as i look
okay
you will be the guy that saves her from
your mom
and she needs an adult in her life to
save her right now
because she's a child
she's 16 she's probably beautiful she's
probably mature growing up in that crap
she's probably real mature but she's a
child
and she needs some adult in her life to
care and love about her have you sat
down and told your dad about this
i had uh he knows about it he knows
about it because she will talk to him
about it
um
i haven't i guess he probably doesn't
know the full extent of it okay um as as
much as my sister has told me and
obviously like i said backtrack and be
like oh maybe i shouldn't have told you
that well she's hiding i hadn't thought
about that i may have screwed that up i
i may call your dad and say here's the
deal i'm gonna sit down have a hard
conversation with mom
sister's in an abusive situation with
step dad with that piece of crap and
um she needs a place to go it's gotta be
your house dad and i'm gonna sit down
and tell mom that she's got a week to
make this the whole thing happen or i'm
gonna call the police and whoever and
let your dad know
i'm about to step in here and be the
adult because no one seems to want to
and hopefully he will say oh my god this
is my daughter
i'll get involved he might not
that's my hope
um i know for a fact he will okay then
good and here's a hard thing this is
another hard conversation that you have
to have
and i'd have it with your sister and
it's gonna feel hard now
but it will be less hard one year down
the road three years down the road and
ten years down the road okay just trust
me on this
you're gonna have to let her know you
told me some things and i said i
wouldn't tell anybody but i have to and
i'm sorry i'm gonna violate your trust
but i can't allow you to be in an
abusive household anymore you're my baby
sister i love you too much
and she may get mad and say i can never
trust you again i'm never gonna tell you
anything and you will be saving her life
okay
okay you will not be taking her from her
mom you will be saving her from her mom
you'll be taking her from a family
you'll be saving her
what a gift that she's got you as an
older brother
and i don't know how you your dad must
be amazing
the fact that you've been able to come
out of this thing with character and
strength and resilience is a testament
to you and those who love you
not to the mess and crap you came out
man i'm proud of you
proud of you this is grown-up stuff
right
sure is it's hard
have you seen somebody yet
i have not
you have to
you trust me you got to
absolutely i see it um i know
as you would say it's a whole other call
but i've seen it crop up in my own
relationships that's right you're hey
this is what you know
you're a child of divorce you're a child
of separation you're a child of abuse
you're a child of parent abandonment and
neglect
when it comes to the aces score the
adverse childhood experiences you can
google that just google aces score and
take that test it's about 10 questions
my guess is
you're at a four okay you know what that
means right
yes you're at an elevated risk for all
sorts of stuff unless you deal with it
man because your body's dealing with it
every minute of every day
and you're gonna replay the scripts that
were rolled out in front of you you're
gonna replay these stories that you got
from your original parents from your
step you're gonna you're gonna replay
that stuff over and over and over and it
may not look exactly the same
but man i can already hear you wanna
protect your mom you wanna protect
because that's what you had to do
between her and that idiot
you want to love your dad talk about how
great he is
he might be right you want to
be the guy who makes sure everybody's
okay dude that's an exhausting
job
not your job that's your mom and dad's
job brother
and i hate they didn't do that for you
so do i have your word you're gonna make
a call you talk to your old man soon
today tomorrow
i will do it today okay i'm proud of you
and then you're going to talk to your
sister
i will okay and your dad may try to talk
you out of it let him know
i'm grown up now grown-up jack i'm 21
year old jack
i can buy beer and guns and i can
protect my sister not necessarily in
that order with those tools right so
grown-up conversations different one
than y'all ever had before probably
right
absolutely yes hey i'm proud of you
call me let me know how that
conversation goes or write me a note and
let me know how that conversation goes
okay it's going to be messy it's going
to be hard you're going to feel isolated
you'll feel alone i want you to call
somebody make sure you've got some
people in your corner too
cool
thank you dr d i appreciate it i'm super
proud of you my brother super proud of
you man
i'll be right back on the dr john
dolone's show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real
licensed therapists if you reach out to
them you will be talking to somebody
within 48 hours dr john delaney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
and we are back all right so they just
dropped some
some wisdom on me
during the break uh earlier
i just looked up and the first person i
saw was ben and i thought i'll take a
cheap shot of ben and ask ben if he
could read
turns 80 has a master's degree in
creative writing and he's a novelist
so that's what i get
what a jerk
it's okay man i have low self-esteem
that's why i lash out i'm sorry i'm
working on it i'm not but i talked i say
that i cannot
uh
good dude what are you writing about
uh is it wizard fiction please say yes
it's weirdly yes yeah
all right i'm gonna just give you the
elevator pitch okay imagine harry potter
was drafted into a modern day war in the
middle east
so it's military drama with fantasy
elements
i literally i'm not gonna be able to
sleep until this thing is written and
comes out i'm a hundred thousand words
deep 100
hey if you publish it here they'll edit
it down to 50.
good god there's a whole other book that
they took away
rumor has it listeners and watchers that
i talk too much and so i think i
submitted like i said a lot of words
good for you keep going don't let the
haters get you down or whatever that
thank you
does the winner win at the end
don't give it away i can't spoil it yeah
i love it all right let's go to kathleen
in detroit rock city what's up kathleen
hi john thanks for taking my call thank
you so much for calling
well i never dreamed i'd be calling you
about this but um about a month ago um
my 16 year old
was
in a psychiatric unit in lockdown
because
he had a plan to
commit suicide
and um
so he was there for 10 days and then um
in an outpatient program for three weeks
so um
we
are blindsided we didn't see
you know that this was coming we knew he
was down and the pandemic's been hard on
everybody
but
um
he went back to school last week so
things are stable
um
[Music]
but we're scared i mean we don't know
you know what this disease is we don't
have any
experience with the psychiatric field so
it's it's all new to us and we're kind
of trying to navigate
and they're kind of over
overextended themselves because there's
so many teenagers that need help right
now
um
and i just don't know how to yeah we we
have no experience we
we don't know
why or you know what causes this but it
it's been diagnosed as a you know it's a
disease really a bipolar one
with psychosis
um
so he does have a diagnosis of bipolar
one with psychosis
that's the preliminary diagnosis and
you know at this point we hope that's
all it is we don't know because
it might be schizophrenia i mean we
don't know they need timing this is the
first time they've seen him so they
don't know um
we don't get a whole lot of information
from the psychiatrist unless we
really um
are forceful and ask um
so it's been tough for us we just don't
know how to navigate it
yeah thank number one thank you for your
trust this is scary i've had this
conversation unfortunately
probably 150 tuner time in my career
i've had this conversation a lot and so
it's heartbreaking and it's scary and
thank you for your trust okay
um
yeah wow
more than 100 oh god i've had this yeah
okay the first thing here okay and this
is me i'm gonna rattle these off top of
my head and um
and so hang in here with me um as we go
through him okay and you don't have to
write all this down you can just keep
this clip and go back and look at it and
listen to it or but you can't write it
down if you'd like okay okay
first and foremost you and your husband
got to be on the same page
and
where this gets hard for everybody is
one person thinks he's faking it or this
is not a big deal or the doctors are
crazy and the other person
wants to wrap the little your boy in
bubble tape and both sides are
understandable
but both sides
point to a
new fissure a new crack in a
relationship
and you
need each other in this season okay
and often i'll recommend you've heard me
recommend on the show before a million
times and i'll do it a million more
times
i recommend you and your husband getting
out when maybe during school take a day
off of work both if you go somewhere and
sit and exhale
take a pad and a pen and just breathe
and then you gotta grieve this thing
because it hurts and it's scary and it
came out of nowhere and you're
blindsided all of those words
you got to hear each other talk about
them
uh david kessler says grief demands a
witness you got to get in front of each
other and say whoa what just happened
okay
okay is that possible are you all in a
position to do that yeah i think we're
on the same page we're both still kind
of in shock and
we're kind of in the bubble wrap both of
us that's right that's right and that's
eight that's where i'd be if my son i
mean i'd be right there okay i'd be
right there
um but get out and have the conversation
about
what do you think of mental health and
what do you think of it and what do we
think about medication what like have
those conversations just so they're said
and the goal here is this when i walk
away and we want to say
we are going to
both agree that we need to get a second
opinion a second diagnostic we both
agree that this doctor seemed credible
we trusted him he looked us in the eye
or she looked us in the eye
invited us in to be a part of this our
son's healing
and we trust him and so we're going to
do what they say because we're not
experts right and sometimes i hear this
and you'll get this a lot why aren't you
doing your own research and my response
is
all right dude if we're googling over
med school then we all have a problem
right you know what i mean
um and that brings me to number two
uh how old's your son
16 16.
so depending on what state you're in
which is most states
you are technically the client
you have access to all of the records
because the kid's a minor
and i would
there's a bit like a like a white coat
like oh this is just us and we don't you
know what
dude
knock the doors down
this is my son i want to know all the
stuff he's seeing saying experience all
of these things
we need to know what he's experiencing
and what y'all diagnosed him with why
you diagnosed him with that i demand a
meeting with y'all
and sometimes he'll have a social worker
that helps mediate those most
psychiatric inpatients do because the
doctors are just going
person to person to person
how did the social worker reach out how
was that
that was good um
it was good but they
again it's not like a medical diagnosis
where they can tell you right you got
cancer we're going to treat it this
that it's sort of a floating diagnosis
they don't really know right which is
disorienting what what kind of meds are
they putting on
a mood stabilizer and an antidepressant
so he's quite
imaginative
zombie like is the word but yeah he's
pretty low it takes a lot longer for the
antidepressant i think to come take
a fact the problem that they have with
him though is he's in general he's very
shut down and they feel he puts
he's he's an extremely good student and
none of his grades suffered which we
can't believe
even with all the psychosis he had over
a 4.0 yeah
um he wants his driving privileges back
and he wants to see his friends again
he's got friends i mean he has a normal
life and he wants to do his activities
and we just we just don't know how
he is stable but we don't know if we
should let him drive or sure and because
these are all questions
that
um somebody's gonna have to tell me
human contact and interaction with
friends and community and loved ones is
not a good idea for me to take that off
the table
someone's gonna have to tell me your kid
cannot do physical activity
because i know connection and physical
activity are really important for
working through and healing from
depression
bipolar is a different story and there's
a whole range that no one getting all
that right now but
um
someone's going to have to sit down and
tell me don't do those things for me to
take those away
and there's also
son you almost died
and you have to know in our world that
that has and you being vulnerable back
to him is an important number three
letting him know and there's some of
this
fear that we don't want to say it out
loud because you know how it's going to
affect him
what he's going to feel is the secret is
the gap
you get what i'm saying
and so there's got to be some sort of
hey
you we love you you scared us
do you want to talk to us will he talk
to you how's those conversations been
a little bit more a little bit better
every day but not
he's very
shut down we can't
my
instinct is to kind of talk talk talk
and impress him but he doesn't
they told us not to press him sure and i
think that's right
yeah he is in therapy as a counselor
yeah twice a week yeah good
would he go on a walk with you or your
husband
um a little bit more with my husband but
my husband doesn't press him to talk so
that's probably why i'm i'm trying not
to it's just my way yeah but so here's
here's i don't think they say much on
their walk hey that's okay
because they're saying everything
okay
one thing you might i'm struggling with
i want him to talk but he won't talk
yeah and right now he's trying to get
he's trying to re
his body is what doesn't feel safe
and he may even buy the fact let's say
he's truly suicidal or when he was
suicidal he he and he had a plan he was
he was he truly was ready to go
yeah and he goes through inpatient
for a week or ten days and then he goes
through outpatient for three weeks
he may come to believe
this feeling i have that i want to go is
not a trustworthy feeling it's wrong
i trust you that i actually want to be
here even though my body's telling me
it's time to go
that's less he's got to learn to feel
safe in his body again
and to get to know his new body
especially one that's heavily medicated
and if he's got bipolar one
with
um
with he's hallucinating too right yep
with psychotic episodes then he will
probably be on medication for the rest
of his life and that's okay
that's completely okay
it's not ideal we don't want that but
thank god we live in an era when that's
possible okay
if
he's got
um has epilepsy or has brain lesions or
has any number of other things he grows
out of this it what you know what i mean
so that's where getting a relationship
with that doctor is so so so important
and you are the parents of a minor and
you all have access to that and you can
demand it and if they won't give it to
you somebody will
okay and i would be in same with the
counselor
i want to know how my kid is doing
and i think a beautiful thing for you to
sit down and say hey listen i solve all
my problems by just talking and talking
and talking and i know that doesn't help
would you take a silent walk with me
just once a day
and let your old mom hold your hand
please
try that yeah that sounds good try that
i've started silent walks with my son
like hey we're just gonna go and they're
never silent because when there's no
pressure when i'm not going to grill him
on math homework whatever
he feels at peace and then when he's at
peace he feels free to start talk talk
talk talk talking and then i get back
and i've learned more about dinosaur i
don't even know we're talking about
anymore right you remember those days
and again all of this is
practicing reestablishing connection and
safety in his body
um
you have to have to have to have a good
partnership with the counselor and a
doctor moving forward
and i hate that they didn't give it to
you
yeah i think they're overwhelmed right
now i know they are i know they are i'm
not going to talk bad about them because
i know they're getting crushed the the
teens are we've just just i mean they're
just melting it's just we're just
absolutely stone melting
it's heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking um does he have
brothers and sisters
who's a sister yeah how old is she yeah
18 18. and she's a senior in high school
so
she's going to be leaving
um
he wants to go away too and just brought
that up the other day out of the blue
and i thought well i don't know if
you're going away or not i mean all of
that is up in here you know yeah and i
think a great answer to that is not no
way because that goes into the see i
told you i shouldn't be here
it should be
oh my goodness let's say his name's ben
come on ben that's a
that's a next month decision
today we're about connecting and getting
well we'll make plans down the road
and or you work we'll work that out with
your counselor as we as we all heal
right and letting him know we're all
healing we're all in this together he's
a part of this unit this unit doesn't
operate without him we need him
one of the things that really was a
light bulb moment for me was reading the
things thomas joyner's work he's one of
the preeminent suicide i just had so
many of these as a college college dean
of students i just kept dealing over and
over and over
and one of the things that was a
lightbulb moment for me was he writes
about
this feeling of perceived burdensomeness
not only do i not have a group but when
i'm around people their life is less
good because i'm in it
and this is rarely it's almost never a
fact
it's just this
sense and so that's why you see people
who look like they've got tons of
friends and they're happy
something inside of them
tells them that other people's lives are
less good when they're around and so
that's what part of the healing journey
is but that's one of those quiet
we're all healing and we're all going to
go do a thing and i know you want to go
like but i think asking your counselor
i'm talking a million different
directions here
talking to hit the counselor asking some
very direct questions can he go hang out
with his friends at night
should we limit video games or cut them
off
completely what does a um one thing i
think would be great for you and your
husband and him is to have a journal
that y'all pass back and forth on each
other's beds and the only requirement is
he's got a ride and he's got to respond
to you too
and you ride in it after he goes to
school
says i'm thinking about you today i want
you to know that you're loved we love
having you here whatever you want to say
to him and you put on his bed and then
he's got to respond to it and put on
your bed before he goes to school
and it might just be he can he writes
thank you
it might just be
today was a good day today was not a
good day whatever it is great but we're
just opening a dialogue that has never
been there
okay and get creative on those things
um silent walks holding hands touch
watching dumb movies whatever it happens
to me i listen to garth brooks on the
way to work today that's the kind of
connection i'm trying to make with my
kid right i don't i'm just trying he
loves 90s country and i'm trying i'm
trying and the songs are good there i'm
working on it but whatever we can do to
start leaning into connection and here's
the final final thing i need you to hear
me say
okay
not your fault
okay okay
okay you're gonna mine everything you've
ever said and ever done and wonder what
you did what you did what you did what
you did
right
right that's true
okay
okay don't do that to yourself don't do
that to your relationships and do that
to him
it's hard i know that
but
we're here now and how do we make
tomorrow a little bit better a little
bit more connected
but the i want you to hear me say if
nothing else i've thrown a lot at you
and i'm talking 90 miles an hour
um
nothing else you have to have a good
relationship with his doctor with a
psychiatrist and with his his ongoing
counselor
they've got to have a back and forth
connection and there may be some things
that he says i don't want to talk to
them about
and you tell the counselor that's okay i
trust y'all i want you all to have some
privacy between the two of you
um some confidentiality between the two
of you
just know that if he ever says i'm gonna
hurt myself they have ethical
responsibilities to go do something
about it
so they're not just gonna sit on
something right um but i want you to be
no they didn't they didn't they let us
know when that came up good good good
good good that's great but
ask as many questions as you can and
don't let them brush you off and be like
well actually this is how our policy is
i don't care your policies that's my son
it's my son right
and i want him to still be here next
year and the year after that and the
year after that and after that and so on
and so forth
healing is gonna be for the whole family
one more thing one more thing on top of
the one more thing take your daughter
out for breakfast and make sure she's
asked ask her how she's processing all
this
yeah okay it'll probably be good for
both of you you can tell her hey i'm
scared caught me blindsided she may have
some insight that you don't know about
often older sisters are brilliant and
really observant
and
it will be a great opportunity for her
to get a ringside seat into what
vulnerability looks like you have a
chance to be honest and direct and say
i'm scared too this scared me to death
this is hard on me and your dad and
she'll go oh this is what being an adult
looks like and it'll be a great gift for
her
okay cool
yes
thank you all right definitely thank you
we'll be thinking about you please let
me know how these things continue as
they continue on
this is so hard so so so hard so so so
so hard hard hard
young people if you're listening to this
if you're thinking about hurting
yourself
don't
call somebody
write
now
call somebody
moms and dads if you even have an
inkling that your kid's not doing okay
it's worth more than any meeting you
have to go to any show you're in the
middle of watching any turn stuff off
and go in your kid's room sit on their
bed and say
what's going on
and they may tell you to shut up and get
out of here i'm doing this whatever you
say you're my son you're my daughter
how are you
you're not okay
and it may mean you miss out on a lot i
mean you gotta change
i'm here for you
and moms and dads if you're not doing
okay
you can't do life by yourself call
somebody
[Music]
i'll be right back with the dr john de
luna show
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood
their meat is less expensive than what i
can get at the grocery store right down
the street and they deliver it to my
door now listen i'm a lunatic about meat
quality and this is the stuff i feed my
family so go to greensbury.com
and you'll get 10 off your first
purchase check it out today your
nutrition is worth it
all right we are back and let's go to
seattle home of the grunge
allison chains the pearl jams
even the sound gardens chris cornell
greatest singer of all time and talked
to rose what's going on rose
hi
how are you
i'm good in you
you don't sound good i'm great
i'm sitting in a
bunch of snow here in nashville how are
you you're not you're not doing okay
yeah i'm just tired all right so what's
up how can i help
well i was just wondering to what level
um you should change for a partner or
how much you should compromise
oh this is a loaded question so unpack
that for me
so
um
well my boyfriend has been telling me
that he wants me to lose weight for him
because he wants me to be the best for
him as he says it and he
he needs to in order for him to find me
more attractive he wants me to lose the
weight and i don't feel like i should be
doing that but then if i'm asking him to
change like
um do things without me having to tell
him constantly or just put in a little
more effort into the relationship i
don't know if it's a double standard
asking him to change and me not changing
so a couple things one i'm just
i'm rarely speechless rose and you made
me speechless so well done i want to
give you a high five on that
um
that's a brazen man
that will look at his
wife
are y'all married girlfriend
girlfriend girlfriend look at his
girlfriend and say
you need to be the best for me
and um you're overweight you're not
attractive fix it
it's a brazen man
brazen man
like where i'm from you get murdered
kind of man
and on the other hand you ask an
interesting question so you want him to
be more emotionally present and what
else
just be able to do things without me
constantly having to tell them to do
them so be invested in the relationship
at all
yeah okay and so
are
man you're asking a great question so
here's what first pops it oh i'm not
even gonna go there now just i'll just
gonna muddy the waters all right so
here's here's the way i think you can
think about this
if somebody let's say my wife let's say
my wife came to me and said hey i need
you to lose weight
and i would say why and she'd say well
i've known you for 25 years and when you
get to be this size whether it's because
you know you're not working out or
you're not eating right or you're
lifting a lot you just get big i snore
or my sleep score goes down or i get a
little grumpy or i'm always she'll
notice things like i say oh my knees or
my back or whatever my neck hurts
whatever
and she'll say hey it's time you need to
get back on a plan and she's not saying
that because
she has suddenly found me unattractive
which is really hard because i'm a smoke
show let's be honest
she's saying
for your health and well-being i love
you and care about you so much i want
you to be your best self
and you've given me permission to speak
into your life and i see patterns
because i've known you for 25 years
one of your patterns is xyz abc
i think it's time
that's different than
i don't think you're pretty
and i deserve pretty so fix it
do you see how those are the same thing
but different
yeah okay
so one of these is i want you to lose
weight because i want you to feel better
i don't not i want you to be the best
for me but i want you to be the best for
you i want you to feel good
and that's different than i need you to
be hotter
and so
the difference is with what you're
saying i love your question
but here's where it's different
let's look at you and let's look at him
and then let's make a triangle with the
relationship okay so you have the
relationship that's separate from both
of y'all
when you get married you both agree that
we are now becoming a single unit
we are becoming this new thing together
we're fusing together
and this gets lost in all of our
cultural talk of marriage
everybody's screwed this thing up when
you're in you're in
and when you do that you say what is the
things that are going to better serve
this relationship
he is saying you be hot not for the
relationship but for me
you are saying
hey would you engage into this
relationship
for us
so this whole unit operates seamlessly
together with one do you see what i'm
saying
yeah the spirit there is so so different
and so i get that yes you're asking him
to change he's asking you to change but
you all are coming at it for two very
different reasons one is incredibly
selfish and demeaning
and the other
is
trying to find common connection
how do we build an ecosystem where we're
both loved and we're both in this thing
does that make sense
yeah it
does how long have you been with this
guy
a little over two years
when did this kind of talk start
um i would say about
six to eight months
into the relationship or six or eight
months ago
uh ago
have you become unhealthy during the
pandemic
no i'm the exact same way i was um when
we met
so what else is going on beneath these
two stories
your relationship is on the rocks what
else is going on
i just feel like i'm not good enough
well he tells you that you know what i
mean
yeah
that's why you feel that way because you
got somebody that says they love you and
then they tell you you're not good
enough for me
it's just confusing because
he says he
wants to be with me but
i don't understand
i tell him it's not
you don't want to be with me you want to
be with a different version of me
and
i just
don't know
what to do hold on can i say something
hard rose
yeah
you do know what to do
you also know that it's to hurt like
bloody hell right
you do exactly know what you what to do
i'm heartbroken for you
you can never do something sustainable
over time for somebody else you gotta do
it for you
yeah
and if you need to lose weight that's a
whole other call
but do it for you
because you want to feel good and you
want to live a long
fun
adventurous life
and when you're 65 you want to roll
around on the ground with your green
kids
you don't want to be tied up to tubes
and machines and pills your whole
adult life
and you want to feel good in whatever
you want to wear i mean there's 100
million reasons why you lose weight
for you
but you don't do it for to please
somebody else because you know why that
kind of pleasing is about power that
kind of pleasing is gonna move so let's
say you lost 100 pounds it would move on
to something else
you need to be this way in bed you need
to start doing this you need to actually
start doing that
it will just move
because it's not about this one thingy
do you have what's something you want to
change what's something you want to get
better at this year 2022. not what
somebody's told you what's something you
want to grow towards
um
get better at my job what's your job
i work in construction okay are you a
baller dude
away i bet you're a boss baller huh what
do you do in construction
um i just started so i just my goal is
just to become more confident
what do you do out on the site
um
i work with concrete
so i pour concrete slab
yes dude i told you you're a gangster
man
so
are you going to get better this year
how are you going to get better
um
work more and i just need to be more
confident and standing up for what i
know yeah i should be doing
so yeah confidence comes from when you
when you are able to
we we live in a culture that says you
just need to be confident no dude our
bodies know and we're not telling the
truth i can get up in front of a bunch
of people and say i'm gonna dive off
this high dive and do a triple double
flip i just need to be confident my body
knows we're about to splat
confidence comes from
a series of little and increasingly
bigger wins
i'm confident enough i played that whole
song in my basement now i'm confident to
play it in front of my kids and then i'm
confident enough to play it at practice
and now i'm confident to play that song
on stage
and you're exactly right work more i
wish there was another way around it but
you're exactly right you got to practice
concrete work over and over and you're
going to screw stuff up and people are
going to go like what are you doing no
girls allowed and you're going to be
like i'm freaking rose the concrete
sorcerer and you're gonna i don't even
know if that's a thing is there
something that's a concrete sorcerer
probably not but you're gonna crush it
and can i tell you something that kind
of breaks my heart and kind of fills my
heart at the same time
what i want you to go back and listen to
this audio when the show comes out
talking about this guy
who has beat you down
i told you that you're not good enough
for him
your voice has a particular tone a
weight to it a heft to it a sadness to
it
and when you started talking about
concrete work you cheered up
you've got joy in your heart about that
and that's awesome
that's awesome
you are worth being loved rose do you
believe that
i'm trying to
i'm not i never lie to somebody on the
show
never gonna lie to you you are worth
being loved
you're also worth feeling good you're
also worth having great physical health
okay
but you're worth being loved for you
now if he comes to you and says hey i
was complete idiot
i said this wrong i screwed up i don't
know what's going on
coveted mess got me nuts i've been
locked down for two years here in
seattle
like listen i'm sorry
i want you to
feel so good
and our relationship will grow if i feel
good if you feel good if we're both
working towards goals that we both
that's a whole different conversation
about weight
right
yeah
so
i'm not gonna make you say it out loud
on this on the radio
you've got a series of hard choices
ahead of you right
yeah do you all live together
we do okay
you got a hard series of of decisions to
make
do you have a girlfriend that you can
sit down and talk to that walks
alongside you through this
[Music]
yeah i do good
what do they tell you
[Music]
basically the same thing
you know why
[Music]
because i love you
because you're worth being well
and you're worth being loved
[Music]
okay
yeah
i'm grateful for your rose i know this
is a hard call
[Music]
man
yeah we'll be right back on the dr john
dalloni show
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely
we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
we'll walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
if you pre-order today you'll get over
several hundred dollars of free bonus
items so go to johndaloney.com to take
the next step towards wellness that's
own your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back hey listen
reminder
my book pre-sale has launched own your
past own your future go to
johndaloni.com there is a ton if you if
you order them pre-sale it's 20 bucks
and you get so much stuff alongside it
free month of counseling you get um
audio but you get all kind of
shenanigans dude johndaloney.com
buy 40 of them for you and your friends
and your family for strangers 40's
probably a lot that er that's kind of
weird um
i'm so grateful for your support and i
really want to get this message out
about
how we can change our
lives all right as we wrap up today's
show
ben
wizard ben the wizard
the middle eastern wizard passed along
his favorite song of all time
reliant k's i so hate consequences and
it goes like this and i'm good good good
to go i got to get away get away from
all my mistakes and i'm good good good
to go
get away from all my mistakes so here i
sit looking at the traffic lights the
red extinguishes the hope that the green
ignites i want to run away i want to
ditch my life because all my mistakes
keep me awake at night man this sounds
like my life sometimes but if my heart
says i'm sorry can we leave it at that
because i just want for all this to end
i so
hate consequences we all do but we all
got them right here on the dr john
dolone's show